pendant blier vous avez des bertrand
votre fils lorsqu'il s'est lancé dans le
ciment très peu très très peu
quand il a décidé de faire du cinéma
seule chose que j'ai pu faire pour lui
et c'est de lui éviter de frapper à des
mauvaise porte c'est à dire que je les
présente et un assistant très important
qui était l'assistant de clouzot de rené
clair de qui s'appelait serge valin et
c'est serge valin qui lui a il a fait
ces stages avec serge alain est un
redoutable assistant à tel point
qu'après il a pratiquement fallu
l'envoyer au ça m'a tellement il en a
bavé mais c'est tout ce que j'ai pu
faire pour lui et lorsqu'il était gamin
si jeudi vous en parliez de cinéma avec
lui il venait vous voir par exemple les
sondages n'ont jamais non non non non je
m'attendais pas du tout à ce cette
évolution de ce qu'il a fait les études
absolument normal plutôt bonne meilleure
que les miennes en tout cas et puis à jo
il a décidé de faire du cinéma d'écrire
j'étais ravi alors non seulement il a
fait du cinéma mais en plus il vous a
fait tourner alors commencer comment
est-ce que ça s'est passé ça a été
difficile à diriger c'est du passé très
normalement donc premier film qui
s'appelait break down on a eu des
problèmes mais qui n'avait aucun rapport
à votre
avec les relations de metteur en scène
et acteur mais sinon moi je tourne avec
lui comme je t'aime avec un autre ça me
plaît beaucoup plus parce que d'abord
c'est un très bon metteur en scène et
ensuite c'est un très bon metteur en
scène l'acteur et puis parce que je le
vois un peu plus souvent que d'habitude
c'est tout et vous vous êtes laissé
diriger sans problème je crois oui mais
c'est à lui qu'il faut demander ça parce
que moi j'ai pas eu de problème en tout
cas et le fait que pour un réalisateur
que son père soit un acteur connu et
apprécié comme ça c'est plutôt une
hygiène ou c'est plutôt un avantage
d'après vous à mon avis c'est une gêne
c'est à dire que j'ai pu l'aider au
départ mais après il a certainement eu
mans n'a jamais parlé mais je suis
persuadé qu'il a dû avoir des problèmes
dans la mesure où il tombé sur des gens
qui devraient éclater un fils ça va oui
je crois que c'est en général un petit
handicap mais pas terrible alors un
petit jugement rapide sur son travail
maintenant qu'est ce que vous en pensez
d'accord mais il est au top niveau mais
c'est un petit test parce que vous ne
saviez pas ce que votre père avait dit
vous il a vu vos études brillantes et
facile
oui alors lâchez pas d'accord 1 mais
peut-être que ça vient du fait que les
miennes était meilleur que les siennes
ça c'est beaucoup ici c'est vrai que vos
rapports avec pays et lui acteur vous
mettez en scène sont simples et très
simplement parce que c'est un bon acteur
l'adoré vous dirigez un bon acteur même
quand on lis avec son père c'est que
sans problème ayé chose qui me fera
beaucoup c'est que on y reviendra tout à
l'heure mais vous avez beaucoup de
pudeur
et votre père dans la façon de vous avez
d'exprimer vos sentiments et la pudeur
vous quitte dès que vous tournez avec la
pudeur c'est ça on en a plusieurs dans
la vie privée et mais pas quand on
exerce notre métier vous défouler un peu
alors se défoulent totalement et autres
mon père l'a prouvé beaucoup plus que
moi
moi j'ai pas je recommence
[Musique]